why didn't bail sign on for a dark
knight four bayo's answer to the
question is as simple as it is
surprisingly humble the actor claimed he
ultimately decided a fourth turn as the
cage Crusader would have been quote over
indulgent Bale explained we were never
arrogant to assume that we had an
opportunity Beyond one film at a time
that's something that Chris always would
talk about he'd say this is it we're
making one film that's all we've got
then when they came and said you want to
go make another it was fantastic but we
still said this is it we will not get
another opportunity Bale went on to
offer that while a Trilogy was far from
a given for Nolan's Dark Knight Saga it
was what the director had in mind from
the start the actor shared Chris had
always said to me that if we were
fortunate to be able to make three we
would stop let's walk away after that
then when they Warner Brothers
inevitably came to us and said how about
a number four I said no we have to stick
to Chris's dream which was always Sue
hopefully do a Trilogy that's not
stretch too far and become over
indulgent and go for a fourth